Eddie Redmayne of course nominated for  his performance and the Danish girl and  two nominations in a row gotta ask you  you know Sandra Bullock made a lot of  fun of the fact that she won a Razzie  back at it you want a Razzie a lot of  gauzy this morning so I'm leaving Los  Angeles with an award whatever happens  so yeah that was for Jupiter ascending I  did what I thought was a bold  performance but I think it was a bit  disastrous but there you go you're  already having a gold moment by the way  I will say that even though you're at  Oscar gold here tonight because you got  a baby on the way that's true this is  true I know so exciting you're easy  reading books like baby book you know we  have just got a couple of baby books I'm  up quite a pathetic reader so but I'm  there's gonna come a moment once all  this madness is over where I'll start  educating myself you know good luck with  that it's the best job you'll ever have  thank you so much